please to have here
future hall-of-famer could be
first-ballot hall-of-famer could be
years from now however when that takes
place depending on certainly how this
conversation goes good to see you again
Terrell absolutely how are you - oh I'm
good now good what do you think about
what you saw with Tony Romo yesterday oh
it was unfortunate and I knew when he
when he got falling on mm-hmm
I saw how his face grimace I knew it
probably could have been that the
collarbone wasn't for sure but as he
walked off I think there was a shot
where he kind of you can read his lips
and he said it's broken okay Briah but I
had a broken collarbone back in 2003 or
four I have a titanium rod in mind yeah
but I think you know time is kind of on
his side because it's early in the year
as far as can he get back and you know
will it be worth the risk you know
considering you know he's gonna be in
harm's way when he comes back how how
can the line protect him but you know I
was talking to the guy drew back back in
the green room and I was telling people
that injury probably could have been
avoided so if you cued the play up I
don't know if you have it but right
before that play he made a check he
obviously checked the play and the
receivers that way why somebody was
supposed to run around in I don't know
if he was in a hot route or something
but if you saw it he went to go throw
the ball but nobody was out there so
somebody ran the wrong route or didn't
get to check so that play definitely
could have been avoided so that's you
know goes to a lot of inexperience I
know they signed the guy I don't know
who price was by Butler
right but somebody see if you see that
yeah somebody ran the wrong route and he
felt the pressure and yeah and suddenly
now he now he's the ball and he's
grandma so are you saying that the Dez
Bryant injury potentially began this
injury absolutely I mean it's been a
snowball effect I mean obviously it's
affected you know the whole organization
at this point obviously they needed
somebody to come in to replace Dez they
brought some other guys in I did you
know I have my agent reach out
see if there was an opportunity there
but they obviously are going in younger
direction but again it's been a snowball
effect if you see as you saw that clip
there that that could have been avoided
Terrell Owens joining me here on the
program so you had your agent called
Jerry Jones Steve and John I just told
him to reach out because I knew that it
was gonna be you know to have a loss
like Dez Bryant that's that's the big
loss in itself you think about the
production that he's had since he been
he's been there that's a big loss as it
is and now you have the loss of of your
starting quarterback in Tony Romo you
talked about you know to two elephants
you know in the room yeah and how about
threes like that's like three elements
in an elevator you talk about you add
DeMarco Murray in the mix did you see
DiMarco on the sidelines screaming about
wanting the ball to you hey you know you
know it couldn't have been me if I would
have been doing that there's no telling
you know I mean it would have been a
headline so let's let's get inside
people's heads real what do you think's
in Dez Bryant's head right now Kioko
you didn't have the same injury but you
did have something of the lower leg
right over the Super Bowl actually in my
rookie year after my rookie year I had a
stress fracture in my fifth metatarsal
which it I think is the same but it was
after the season when I got when I had
mine and so I had a screw inserted but
the thing is you know for for that type
of injuries weight bearing and on top of
that you gotta wait for the bone to heal
so I know when they said you know I
guess the first diagnosis like four to
six weeks or something like that I'm
like nah that's it's gonna be definitely
longer than that now you're looking at
you're eight to ten week range and then
now you talked about him getting himself
back in shape he has to be comfortable
to where he can plant because it's not
like he's a lineman or anything not
really doing a lot of movement but he's
he's at a position where he has to make
a lot of cuts and he use his feet you
know to to do what he needs to do well
you obviously know what it means to be a
receiver to be a receiver outside the
numbers many too many ways to be a
receiver that's dependent on and
certainly one with a burning fire inside
that sometimes it spills out what do you
think
would be the pitfalls for Dez Bryant in
trying to make a comeback this year -
you um probably trying to rush it you
know try to rush and get back you know
that's again it's one of those injury
where it's weight-bearing it'll be a
different thing if it was maybe the arm
or something like that but to do and
play like he plays it's gonna require a
lot of time and so I don't know what
he's doing it is for his rehab is
concerned hoping I know that the
training staff is doing what they can
yeah but again he needs to do whatever
he can the right way to heal as fast as
possible I know for myself I'll be
sleeping in a hyperbaric chamber you
know on a daily basis what is that like
it's not bad it's uh it's if you're not
claustrophobic you know it's good I mean
again it accelerates the healing process
and so for me and you know I ate healthy
you know during the course of my career
nothing that that's what allowed me to
come back from a lot of injuries eating
bad foods processed foods it really you
know it hinders the the healing process
of injuries
I'm here with Terrell Owens at Terrell
Owens on Twitter joining me here on the
Rich Eisen show so what's going through
DeMarco Murray's head right now because
my gosh I I can only imagine he's like I
I can only imagine what he's thinking
but I mean right now I mean what would
you do if you were DeMarco Murray right
now what would you do after that
performance or that scheme if you will
against his former team and that day
against well I think it's I mean
obviously it starts up front you know
those guys up front it they should take
a lot of pride in what they're doing in
their job because you can't have a guy
that was leading rusher last year come
in and he doesn't even have 12 hearts
this year it's a it's pathetic I think
you know for somebody that's on the
offensive line they should have a lot of
pride in themselves even the offensive
line coach they should be embarrassed
and at the performance of their guys in
front because that's where it starts I
mean DeMarco can only do what those guys
are front allow him to do if they're not
you know moving guys a front then you
know they can have Herschel Walker they
can have both
acting back there they could have you
know Barry Sanders back there it's not
going to happen and I know you know
DeMarco is pretty frustrated and I'm
sure it was very evident you know as he
walked through the sidelines you know he
was uh he had a lot of outbursts but
again I'm sure he's probably rethinking
you know some of his officers offseason
moving like man what what did I do
should he go in to Chip Kelly's office
and say something but today what I'm he
said last night and I mean I mean again
it starts up front you know no matter
what DeMarco Murray goes in there and
says to Chip Kelly you know that's Chip
Kelly's team he shipped a lot of guys
out of there you know to get what
they're seeing on the field on Sunday so
it really kind of starts with management
you know and works its way down but deed
the product that you're seeing on the
football field for the Philadelphia
Eagles that lies heavily on with Chip
Kelly's shoulders because I know he made
a lot of offseason moves within the last
two or three years even from you know
some of the interior lineman you think
about you know some of the guys like
DeSean Jackson shady McCoy Macklin I
mean a lot of guys that you know that
could probably could have helped them
you know from an offensive weapons
standpoint and even the receivers that
are out there I mean it looks at element
elementary what do you mean by that I
mean it just doesn't look like quality
football did that team doesn't look like
a professional football team I guarantee
you there may be some top high school
teams that could probably come in and
compete against you really think that
about the ether III I had just gotten
off a flight and caught the last part of
the game not the last part I guess
around the second quarter that's when
Tony got hurt or something like that
that that was that was terrible that was
so poor football that I saw so let's
talk about you now so again your agent
calls the Dallas Cowboys and they said
what no thanks I'm not sure what the the
situation is I think there are you know
my name may have come up in discussion
as far as bringing me in but again a lot
of people are going to factor in my age
as far as why I can't play we all know
what had
when I was there and and there are some
things said where it kind of made a
fractured you know the relationship
between myself and Witten and Romo and
again you know time has passed and
hopefully you know they know that I've
moved on beyond that maybe hopefully
they have but for me you know it's all
about giving you know myself an
opportunity that's all I ever really
wanted sure um again a lot of people
talk about the Hall of Fame I don't even
think about it I'm very honored to be
inside that appear to be in such a class
with a number of people as far as the
nominations are concerned but for me
it's you know as I said I don't really
think about it because I know I still
probably should be playing you know so
for me it's just if an opportunity
arises then I'll entertain it and why
wouldn't I want to go back to somewhere
where I I know I felt at home I know the
owner you know I was there with some of
the guys that are still there and yeah I
mean I love my time to dad was so the
idea that if for eight games ten games
whatever that you would push back for
five more years induction in the Hall of
Fame that is something you don't give
any phones it doesn't really bother me
and you know for like I said I'm very
honored Cherno to to be a nominee but I
I never really played the game to to
achieve such an accolade when I came out
of high school and I went to UT
Chattanooga I had no idea that you know
I was gonna become who I became you know
I was a day in scrawny lanky kid that
really just kind of just progressed I
was a late bloomer and things just come
to start happening for me I was all I've
always been competitive I wanted to play
basketball I played three years
basketball my years a cot in college at
UT Chattanooga the best times of my
times in college was when I played
basketball
mm-hm again I never really looked beyond
the collegiate level
it's forth playing professionally
playing football
well one of the things I love about
having you on is because you're so
honest and you
answer any question asked of you so that
that's my way of giving you the caveat
today this question I preached for
people who are out there listening to
the show driving around or watching it
wherever they are right now and thinking
you know what why should the Dallas
Cowboys in the middle of all of this
give a chance to how old exactly are you
41 41 year old who might blow up the
locker room for coming back
why should he Jerry Jones go ahead and
do something like that how do you
respond well for me I'm not that same
guy that I was years ago and I know you
know throughout my career that there are
some things that may have you know not
made I shouldn't have said it
and I think that comes with the
maturation process and for me you know I
respect Jerry I respect the organization
and and me now knowing if there was an
opportunity for me to go back I wouldn't
want to ruffle those feathers you know I
think you know for me I've become wiser
you know as you get older and you know
that's never really been my you know
intentionally my mo to go in there and
disrupt any locker room sometimes my
competitive edge you know gets the best
of me and you know for me I would have
to really kind of curtail that a little
bit but you know as far as me being on
the football field I think everybody
knows you know what they all get nothing
you know right now Brandon I mean he has
a job you know he has a tall order
because you know they're in a locker
room now that whole team that whole city
there too or no but they don't really
feel to a no going against this Sunday
against the Atlanta Falcons who are
locked and loaded with all their weapons
they are that so you know it's it's
gonna be interesting interesting next
few games to kind of see what kind of
identity that they can come up with to
really kind of you know kind of keep
things going for them Terrell Owens is
right here in the studio we take a break
and we come back have about one more
quick segment with you before we send
you on thanks for coming on the program
absolutely shipping more with Terrell
Owens at Terrell Owens on Twitter right
here on the Rich Eisen show
my second time welcome back sit again
but yeah that was my second time seeing
that clip but I knew what happened I
mean with bright spot ler they got top
of the screen who didn't run the right
right or not cuz I saw you know I'm I'm
a very visual person so I saw Tony make
the chicks on new it was and you was
inaudible so I knew somebody supposed to
be doing something so when he got and he
he got ready to throw it and nobody was
there
mmm he felt the pressure and then that's
why you know you know getting sex yeah
that like said I could have been totally
avoided if you were there absolutely
running the route you said it I did it
well I did say it I said it yesterday on
game day morning you said it I heard
about with number 88 sitting at the end
of the at the end of the set perfect oh
yeah yeah yeah oh yeah
and we're like not in their heads I mean
look it's the age thing to you know that
I'm not telling you he tells us yeah
yeah I mean 41 how many so how many you
wouldn't have to go through any
conditioning drill clearly we well I
mean I mean I'll be winded I'm allowed
to get myself in Lewis a so the few be
in-game you name you get a call today
you play Sunday you probably yeah I give
a few snaps how buddies that let's get
out there Walker said he had ten in
number yeah at age 53
yeah by the way you use the last guy to
sit in this chair was Herschel Walker oh
really yeah mmm-hmm you said 53 give 10
he could at least return kicks he said
at least oh very late so what what do
you give me 20 30 snaps you get I guess
I'm thinking okay let me see when I
played I average with something like me
about 70 75 yes now sometimes no I give
you about at least good 30 good 30 for
Sunday
yeah against the Atlanta Falcons good 30
the 50 and Beyond
don't get there yeah that's what people
are talking about yeah I mean red zone
did you have your agent call any other
teams at all no he knows he knows I'm
you know staying you know somewhat ready
you know just in case
would you ever play in Canada uh no I
haven't really thought about it
no no
yeah bright lights right he's he's the
best he's domestic he's domestic United
States right now if they're my if the
price is right yeah bundle up welcome
back to the Rich Eisen show at Terrell
Owens spending a couple more minutes
with me here on the program I always
been extra I appreciate it I appreciate
you I appreciate you coming in I've
spent as much time as you want here
we're seeing some young guns in the NFL
right now at the position it's not just
like okay Calvin et cetera et cetera
we're seeing O'Dell right and we're
seeing julio jones yeah who was the best
receiver in the NFL right now that's a
good question I mean you think about
what Antonio Brown is doing oh my gosh
when was that 2 or 2 yards receiving it
yeah well Steve Smith and do bad either
oh the radio Jay like a 10 for 150 Larry
Fitzgerald had his first three touchdown
game of his regular season career
yesterday
oh yeah that's yeah these are guys you
know letting everybody know that you
know we're not we're not oh yeah you
know that's right okay don't count us
out but yeah you those guys that you
mentioned but one play one play the rod
receiver that you think would do you've
got to get that first down got to get
that score something was the one
receiver that you but I gotta go with
Calvin Johnson cuz he's a big body you
throw it in anywhere in his vicinity I'm
yeah he's gonna make that catch I mean
you know Odell I mean he has to fame now
and just start him you know with that
one spectacular catch but I mean he is
doing what he's doing to piggyback that
and that's being productive for his team
now they need to just start winning some
ball games so they just gave Eli that
extension so you know he's gonna have to
make do with that that money they just
paid him so Jerry Jones said he was
weren't more down more depressed than a
crippled crickets ass he said that
yesterday after the Tony Romo injury so
you are he might wonder the antidote
right do you want to add us snakes to
that too low but you have that antidote
I've got 30 seconds left you are the
antidote correct oh you know I
definitely could be
you know I I'm viable I'm ready you know
give me give me a week or so get myself
in some some game shape I can definitely
I could be of some help you know deal
thank you for coming in you were welcome
here anytime sir you say that you know
that I need a job rich hey this is a
show within the show I like that show
within the show right